bonjour je m'appelle TER West
vous vous
[Applaudissements]
aimz comme tout le
monde qu' é les
je Fabian
vous ex
intionoup syp
pourille
elle est très mure pour une fille de son
âge 21 désolé mon cœur c'est
22 vous n'avez pas vous inquiéter pour
elle des cheveux noirs et plus de
mascara je sais pas trop si
j'aime comment ça tu sais pas trop si
t'aimes il n'est pas comme tu
l'imagines
tu sais il y a plein de rumeurs qui
circulent sur vous
deux est-ce que tu as quelque chose à
cacher
[Musique]
C il me faut une femme capable de
comprendre que ce genre de chose peut
arriver tu veux être cette femme ou
[Musique]
pas
je te quitte pour avoir une vie à
[Musique]
moi